bonsoir fait bien gibeau merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
que la plupart des pays européens
renforcent la restriction l'italien a
donc décidé de rouvrir on l'a vu musées
restaurants et bars pour quelle raison
une raison économique
il ya bien sûr plusieurs réseaux ce
choix bien sûr il ya le facteur
économique ça c'est évident puisque
l'italie dans un pays basé sur la
restauration basée sur le touriste il
est évident que restaurants et musées
devenait problématique mais il ya
également en général des chiffres assez
encourageant et je prends que pour
l'état italien aujourd'hui c'est une
sorte de test de tentative puisque les
chiffres sont encourageants
eh bien on revoit la population s'il ya
des responsabilités à être raisonnables
même avec les autorisations sortie de
manière à faire repartir l'économie donc
plus en plus très attention et on
respecte les gestes barrières et en
faisant voyager justement vous laisser
alors on a vu aussi évidemment des
révoltes 1 dans les pays voisins plus
honneur 1 le danemark notamment les pays
bas un expert en italien walter richie
ad en santé publique conseiller du
ministre italien de la santé a déclaré
chez vous actuellement il est
extrêmement difficile de proposer des
mesures sévères en raison de la
résistance des politiques et de
l'opinion publique est ce qu'on en est
là également en italie
on craint
vraiment la fronde de la population il
ya plusieurs problèmes puisque bondir le
gouvernement thaï est également aux
crises politiques actuellement n'y a
plus de gouvernement une phase de
réflexion d'un mouvement de gouvernement
peut-être qu'au changement de président
du conseil dans la semaine ou un
troisième gouvernement et tous étaient
comptés dans tous les cas il est évident
aussi que en un sens les choix qui
pourrait être vraiment stratégique est
très fort c'est un peu de suspens c'est
plus et régions aujourd'hui qui décide
actuellement des restrictions qu'on
pourrait le faire l'état met à bien
décidés en général de relations
générales et après chaque région gère de
façon locale de manière à maintenir des
normes de sécurité dont marc vivien
d'énormes efforts justement la vénétie
également mais dans l'ensemble on va
dire que vu la crise politique actuelle
il ya le gouvernement italien les
décisions importantes soient au suspense
est justement vous parlez des régions il
faut préciser que les peaux et la
sardaigne la sicile où vous êtes
l'ombrie et la province de bolzano
autonome sont restés au niveau d' alerte
orange la situation était préoccupante
particulièrement dans dans ces régions
il ya plusieurs facteurs différents
selon les régions bien sûr un des
secteurs bien entendu c'est aussi
locales parfois pour la 6 6 par exemple
c'est le président de la région qui a
aussi voulu rester dans une zone plus
orange pour tenir plus la population il
va y avoir des grands événements aussi
culturelle ce mois ci en italie le
carnaval qui est très senti surtout nord
de l'italie va y avoir la fête de sainte
agathe akata cette semaine qui est une
fête qui portent des centaines de
milliers de personnes dans la ville
donc il y a aussi peut-être une
préoccupation par rapport à d'autres
événements culturels qui pourrait
convoquer justement des risques
sanitaires et donc il ya se maintient
dans certaines régions de la situation
rouge mais les couleurs sont toujours
assez relative en général puisque la
région peut toujours aussi décidé de
modifier certaines lois de ces zones de
ces normes de ces de ses choix
politiques donc par exemple pour la
scolarité pour les écoles chaque région
qu'elle soit jaune orange rouge aussi
de gérer comme elles le souhaitent de
rouvrir ou de fermer les yeux en tout
cas l'om est celle pourtant averti qu'il
était trop tôt pour assouplir assouplir
les restrictions comment réagit la
population italienne ce qu'elle est à la
fois peut être soulagé que la ville se
desserre un peu mais tout de même
inquiète que ce alexei des conséquences
compliqué on se souvient que l'italie a
été à l'origine de cette épidémie en
europe en tout cas a durement souffert
et il ya beaucoup d'interrogations
paradoxalement finalement cette crise du
coït cette semaine est passé un peu au
second plan de l'actualité puisqu'il ya
plus de gouvernement et que c'est un peu
la grande occupation est ce qu'il y aura
une majorité mais ce qu'il y aura des
élections anticipées
quand tu as certainement une majorité
mais forcément on va dire la situation
politique appuyé le parent d'un point de
vue de l'actualité
il est évident que les italiens au
général seront plutôt satisfait de
redécouvrir le plaisir d'aller au
restaurant de redécouvrir le plaisir
d'aller dans les cafés mais il ya très
certainement un facteur aussi aux
traumatismes jeu s'entend par rapport
aux italiens que je fréquente une
certaine attention générale pas faire
attention dans tous les cas pour ne par
justement replonger je pense qu'il ya un
certain sens des responsabilités de
chacun merci beaucoup en tout cas fabien
gibbons enseignant à l'université de
turin pour avoir évoqué cette situation
en italie